[Musica]
buonasera buonasera
secondo uno studio recente pubblicato da
science le bambine già sei anni iniziano
a pensare di essere meno brave dei loro
compagni maschi quindi già dalla prima
elementare
iniziano a credere che i maschi siano
più bravi di loro anche se non c'è
nessuna evidenza scientifica ovviamente
che lo dimostra anzi anche se al
contrario di solito mediamente a scuola
sono proprio le femmine a essere più
brave com'è possibile che gli ha messo
in testa che i maschi siano
ontologicamente più bravi di loro
una delle teorie più convincenti per
spiegare questo fenomeno è quella del
cosiddetto curriculum nascosto che
sembra un po il titolo di una teoria
cospirazionista ma in realtà non è così
i libri per bambini i materiali
didattici i cartoni animati i film per
famiglie non sono soltanto
intrattenimento servono ai bambini a
formare un idea del mondo e servono alla
società a passare di generazione in
generazione
i valori che vengono considerati
fondamentali per lo sviluppo
dell'umanità 6 cappuccetto rosso avesse
ascoltato la mamma non sarebbe stata
mangiata dal lupo ascolta la mamma se i
genitori della bella addormentata nel
bosco avessero invitato la fatina
anziana al battesimo l'incantesimo non
si sarebbe abbattuto sul castello
rispettate gli anziani ma quando si
parla di personaggi femminili
quali sono i messaggi che stiamo
mandando alle bambini attraverso queste
storie lasciate che vi leggiamo l'inizio
di tre fiabe celeberrime cenerentola
biancaneve e barbablù cenerentola c'era
una volta tanto tempo fa una vedova che
aveva due figlie bruttine e anche un po
antipatica biancaneve
c'era una volta una bella principessa di
nome biancaneve aveva i capelli neri
come l'ebano la bocca rossa come una
rosa e la carnagione bianca come la neve
barbablù c'era una volta un uomo molto
ricco per disgrazia quest'uomo aveva la
barba blu e ciò lo rendeva così brutto e
terribile che non c'era donna o ragazza
che non scappasse vedendolo una sua
vicina una gran signora aveva due figlie
bellissime e gli domandò una in moglie
lasciandole la scelta di dargli questa o
quella vi stiamo dicendo prima di tutto
costantemente che il loro valore come
esseri umani risiede nella loro bellezza
se non sei bella non esiste ma date se
un uomo è brutto non solo può esistere
ma può diventare ricco si può sposare
numerose volte disfarsi delle proprie
mogli misteriosamente
e nonostante questo nessuno gli nega una
nuova moglie stiamo dicendo alle nostre
bambine che ritrovarsi sposate con un
uomo violento ma ricco è meglio che non
sposarsi ha fatto pensate alla bella e
la bestia la bestia un uomo così
riprovevole da essersi letteralmente
trasformato in una bestia ma la bella
non scappa a gambe levate dal castello
ma dedica la sua vita a redimerlo quando
vi chiedete perché tante donne rimangono
accanto a uomini violenti così a lungo
pensate al curriculum nascosto pensate
che attraverso queste storie
questo è il sistema di valori che stiamo
passando alle nostre bambine
voi direte che queste sono storie
tradizionali che i libri sono cambiati
nel frattempo che i bambini oggi non
leggono barbablù allora andiamo a vedere
un po di dati ed i numeri sui libri e la
tv per bambini una specie di fotografia
dei media per bambini degli ultimi 50
anni
innanzitutto il 100 per cento dei libri
per bambini hanno almeno un personaggio
maschile
invece il 25 per cento dei libri per
bambini non hanno neanche un personaggio
femminile e quasi il 40 per cento dei
libri per bambini non hanno neanche un
personaggio femminile parlante e infine
soltanto nel 18,5 per cento dei cartoni
animati i personaggi femminili hanno una
professione o ambizioni professionali
contro oltre l'ottanta per cento dei
personaggi maschili
ora noi sappiamo che i bambini
utilizzano le storie ovviamente per
costruirsi un idea del mondo in cui
vivono utilizzano le fiabe e le storie
per capire come funzionano le cose e
qual è il loro ruolo nel mondo i loro
con quali sono i loro compiti
ma che tipo di mondo genera una
letteratura per l'infanzia così severa
nei confronti delle bambine
e questa la domanda che noi ci siamo ci
siamo chieste quando abbiamo deciso di
creare storie della buonanotte per
bambini ribelli
abbiamo pensato a una letteratura che
trasmettesse alle bambine modelli di
coraggio di affermazione di sé di
resilienza e di determinazione esempi
presi dal mondo reale non dal regno
della fantasia
abbiamo pensato a una narrazione da
trasmettere di generazione in
generazione il cui obiettivo fosse
celebrare la femminilità e il progresso
dei diritti una raccolta in cui le donne
non fossero in competizione per sposare
un principe ma formassero alleanze per
deporre tiranni come nel caso delle
sorelle mirabal per scrivere la storia
del tennis come nel caso delle sorelle
williams una raccolta di fiabe in cui le
madri adottive non cercassero
disperatamente di disfarti di disfarsi
delle proprie figlie male aiutassero a
diventare campionesse olimpioniche come
nel caso della madre adottiva di simon
buysse la ginnasta americana una
raccolta in cui mariti non fossero
mostri che tengono in ostaggio le
proprie figlie ma compagni di avventura
come il marito di alfonsina strada che
il giorno del loro matrimonio le regalò
una bicicletta perché aveva capito di
aver sposato
una campionessa che voleva solo vederla
correre e vincere
non c'è niente di nuovo in una storia
una storia esprime sempre una visione
del mondo e una storia per bambini a
maggior ragione esprime una una visione
del mondo che vogliamo costruire
quando la tradizione però invece e
oppressione non bisogna temere di essere
ribelli siamo noi d'altra parte a fare
la cultura e non è la cultura a fare noi
prendiamoci allora questa responsabilità
e diciamo a tutte le bambine ribelli del
mondo
sognate più in grande puntate più in
alto lottate con più energia e nel
dubbio
ricordate avete ragione voi grazie
[Musica]